[تصفيق]
حسنًا ، مساء الخير جميعًا ، كانت حرب بوتين
بالفعل إخفاقًا استراتيجيًا
لروسيا ، لقد كشفت نقاط ضعفها العسكرية عن
اقتصادها الذي تعرض لأضرار بالغة لسنوات قادمة ، حيث
شكل مستقبلها كشريك صغير ومستعمرة اقتصادية للصين بسبب
أخطاء بوتين التي
أضعفت طموحاتها الانتقامية.  من قبل حلف شمال الأطلسي الذي
أصبح أكبر وأقوى
هذه المرة يوم السبت الماضي ، انبهرنا جميعًا
بمشاهد
التحدي المسلح لـ Evgeni pagosian
للدولة الروسية حيث استولت قوات Wagner شبه العسكرية
لفترة وجيزة على روستوف وتحركت
ثلثي الطريق إلى موسكو قبل
العودة إلى الوراء
كما أوضح الرئيس بايدن أن هذه
مسألة روسية داخلية شاركت فيها
الولايات المتحدة ولن يكون لها
أي دور ، فمن
اللافت للنظر أن باغوزيان سبق
أفعاله بإدانة لاذعة لمنطق
الكرملين الكاذب
لغزو أوكرانيا نهاية
روسيا.  سلوك القيادة العسكرية
للحرب ، تأثير هذه الكلمات وهذه
الأفعال سوف تلعب لبعض
الوقت تذكيرًا حيويًا بالتأثير المدمر
لحرب بوتين على مجتمعه
ونظامه ،
يشكل العدوان الروسي
اختبارًا هائلاً لكن الصين هي الدولة الوحيدة  حيث
كل من النية لإعادة تشكيل
النظام الدولي
والقوة الدبلوماسية الاقتصادية والعسكرية والتكنولوجية للقيام بذلك
في عالم اليوم ، لا يريد أي بلد أن
يجد نفسه تحت رحمة كارتل
واحد للمعادن والتقنيات الهامة
وخاصة بلد
أظهر  الإرادة والقدرة
على تعميق تلك
التبعيات وتسليحها ، فإن الإجابة على ذلك لا تكمن
في الانفصال عن اقتصاد مثل الصين ،
والذي سيكون من الحماقة ، ولكن تقليل
المخاطر والتنويع بشكل معقول من خلال تأمين
سلاسل التوريد المرنة التي تحمي
الحافة التكنولوجية لدينا والاستثمار في
عدم الرضا عن القدرة الصناعية.  ستستمر الحرب
في تقويض القيادة الروسية
تحت النظام الغذائي الثابت
لدعاية الدولة وممارسة القمع الذي
يخلق الاستياء فرصة مرة واحدة في
جيل لنا في وكالة المخابرات
المركزية في جوهرنا ، وهي خدمة استخبارات بشرية
لا نسمح لها بالذهاب هباءً
شكرًا لك